tout ça ça vient d'une envie de repartir
sur de nouvelles bases solides et celles
ça sera vraiment une destination
ale
il nous faut plus de thunes
ça me gêne pas
c'est un coup de jeune on démolit pas
tout mais il y a quand même des trucs à
casser
dis-moi et ça c'est si on est tarif
S
[Musique]
j'aimerais surtout avoir une attitude
plus positive
[Musique]
l'horloge tourne on va vous envoyer
quelques semaines dans une école de
cuisine on est encerclé de Sydney ici ne
les regarde pas dans les yeux
ce serait pour 5 jours par semaine ouais
je bosse pas le vendredi Nils samedi
est-ce que je peux parler au chef c'est
moi dis-moi
[Musique]
tu vas y arriver oui chef
alors comment ça va depuis le temps
faut qu'on se donne à fond faut que tout
soit nickel
j'aime beaucoup le nom que tu as choisi
tu peux pas te souvenir du nom bien sûr
que je me souviens du nom on n'a jamais
donné le nom
ton futuriste
sur ton t-shirt c'est marqué c'est une
faute d'impression une pièce collector
[Musique]